[Music]
that wild game-winning hail mary
touchdown for the raiders
were the fourth longest game-winner with
under 15 seconds in the last 10 years
you go back
even say the last five years you've seen
the miracle at miami the motown miracle
and
the minneapolis miracle but for raider
nation this one comes at just the right
time the raiders can't lose this one and
be considered for the postseason
so their hopes are still alive because
of this throw the nfl labeled this the
miracle
at the meadowlands
coming carr put some air under it
wide open for the touchdown
[Applause]
miraculous car and company needed a
miracle
oh and they got the miracle but so many
things had to go right for the raiders
to pull that off
in fact john gruden talked about it this
afternoon
i think a lot of people are you know
what what about that call that the jets
made
you know what about the pickup that uh
darren waller made on the edge what
about the blitz pickup by
jalen richard are you kidding me what
about the throw under intense fire
uh and what about the route um and that
to me was
was uh as exciting and as as amazing as
any call that anybody made but
there was some great execution there a
lot of teams would have quit
i think in that situation because it
looks like it's a dire moment
but it's a credit to these guys they
play hard and they play till the end
and um we found a way to win in carolina
wasn't pretty we found a way to win on
the last play of the game with instant
replay against the chargers
we found a way to win against the jets
all right now the raiders keeping their
postseason hopes alive with that win
they are a game back at the colts
hey and look who's coming to town this
sunday the colts 1 p.m kickoff here on
channel 8 can you imagine if fans would
be allowed to go inside boy